ahora quiero hacer una serie de
problemas clásicos que normalmente
aparecen en las competencias y en
algunas pruebas estandarizadas a primera
vista pueden intimidarnos pero después
de observar este vídeo te darás cuenta
que solo es cuestión de saber
observarlos y no son difíciles veamos
primero este
amás bmc es igual a 7 y nos preguntan a
que es igual 5 a 5 b 5 c la primera
reacción es si nada más tengo una sola
ecuación con tres variables con a b y c
como voy a resolver para 5 a 5 b y 5 se
piensa un poco en esto pero la idea
central aquí es darse cuenta que 5 a más
5 b + 5 c no es nada más que cinco veces
a más ve más si distribuimos el 5 en 5 a
5 b y 5 c obtenemos 5 a más 5 b + 5 c
otra forma de pensarlo es que estamos
actualizando el 5 si lo factor izamos
tenemos 5 que multiplica a b c y ahora
como evaluamos esto pues la primera
ecuación nos da toda la información que
necesitamos porque nos dijeron que a más
b más c es igual a 7 a más ve más c es
igual a 7 y esto entonces es lo mismo
que poner 5 veces y creo que ahora lo
empiezas a ver con claridad
cinco veces siete lo cual se evalúa
directamente entonces 5 veces 7 es igual
a 35
y vamos a hacer otro de este tipo para
que vayan familiarizándose con la idea
ahora nos dicen que a veces es igual a
menos uno y tenemos dos variables
adicionales x más igual a 7 y ahora nos
preguntan por esta ecuación espeluznante
te voy a dar unos segundos para que
pienses en esto
bueno lo que se puede observar es que en
la primera actuación tenemos tres
variables y luego tenemos una segunda
ecuación con dos variables en total
tenemos cinco variables con dos
ecuaciones y no se ve forma de cómo
resolver esto es decir va a estar muy
complicado ver de manera individual el
valor de a o b o c o equis o ye
utilizando la experiencia previa vamos a
ver si podemos reagrupar esto de otra
manera vamos a hacerlo voy a observar
primero es de manera alfabética las hace
entonces tengo menos 9 y luego voy con
la vez tengo menos 9 y luego menos 9 c y
creo que empieza a saber hacia dónde voy
ahora vamos con las xy las 10 y tengo
menos 7x y aquí tengo menos 7 y aquí con
verde se ve las x y las yes todo lo que
he hecho fue reescribir esta expresión y
ahora observemos esta primera parte y
parece que hace sentido escrito de esta
manera podemos observar qué es lo que
está ocurriendo observó que en estos
términos con
puedo factorizar el menos 9 y obtengo
menos 9 que multiplica a b c y estos dos
términos de acá puedo factorizar el
menos siete y queda menos 7 que
multiplica a xd es si quisieras
verificarlo sólo es cuestión de
distribuir y llegarás a la expresión
anterior multiplica menos 9 x
más b más se distribuyendo y obtienes lo
que está aquí y ahora podemos ver con
claridad que es más bmc pues aquí arriba
nos dice que a más bmc es igual a menos
1 así que todo lo que está aquí esta
expresión en el paréntesis es igual a
menos 1 y x + a que es igual pues no lo
están diciendo aquí x + d es igual a 7
lo vamos a poner con su color así que
todo esto se simplifica a menos nueve
veces menos uno si menos nueve veces
menos uno menos siete veces
si siete veces siete y si evaluamos
menos nueve por menos uno nos da nueve
positivo y menos siete por siete nos da
menos 49 y entonces 9 menos 49 es igual
a menos 40